[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey we start at three Sharp
sometime 305 sir hello and welcome to
the break room Our Daily Show that keeps
you updated on all the energy news you
need to know uh today we're just talking
about that Bonker She-Hulk finale uh
finally a finale
um there's a lot to talk about yeah a
lot of unanswered questions
someone didn't finish college that's not
I wasn't meant to be a judgmental thing
the prompter does say finally instead of
finale but again finally I would have
been I've been more than willing to move
on if Tommy hadn't gone I went to Ron
Burgundy but we were like fine
hey you know what I'm not ashamed of my
illiteracy just super chat us so I can
go back to school
glue put it hey yo put in the chat if
you think scar can read
um today on today's show uh we
appreciate everybody that's already
chatting sending us hey Corey can't
really coming through with a super chat
already uh if um everybody at Super
chats today we're gonna try to read any
questions your thoughts your predictions
your theories about that She-Hulk finale
uh that we all loved uh we're gonna try
to get to all of it we appreciate all of
you
um but with me here today to discuss
said finally finale we've got Coy we've
got Whitney and Tommy hey so happy to be
here everyone yeah uh like I said
yesterday I don't do comedy anymore uh
just a straight News man so uh yeah I'm
looking forward to just delivering the
facts on She-Hulk and uh just getting
down to business and without further Ado
yeah it's not a bit it's my new life
I don't I don't do jokes anymore uh the
jokes were fun we had a great run doing
jokes but the jokes are finished now
yeah that was uh that was more of a 2022
thing and this is
is going to be about literature and
literacy finally yeah okay I think it's
more finale who this weekend I'm gonna
go home and read a non-fiction book
about John Lennon okay I mean sure uh
okay uh speaking of absurdities uh how
about that Shield finale huh
um so we were talking and there's a lot
to talk about this episode we're gonna
try to get to all of it but one of the
biggest implications for the MCU snuck
in there at the end Bruce Banner showing
up to the family picnic and being like
meet my son scar yeah okay also doing
the weird like he hit him behind his
body like he was like they had to like
plan that he was like yeah when we get
in there hide behind me so no one can
see you I want you to be a reveal also
scar already mastering the like
disgruntled teenager thanks I don't want
to be at this family party thing okay
also though did the the a backyard
family party remind you guys of the fast
enough it was about family it was about
family and that was 50 years as long as
it's a Corona and he likes the tuna here
yes no crust it reminded me of that it
also reminded me this is maybe a deeper
cut the True Blood finale where like
everybody but like three main characters
had died and it was like they're uh all
the survivors sitting around a picnic
table like laughing and like nothing
like they hadn't just lived in like a
vampire werewolf hellscape for the last
like five years of their lives they're
like past the chicken past the macaroni
salad
they all smiled and that was it so
you're saying the um people at the the
banner family picnic should have been
more traumatized yes yeah oh 100 yeah uh
by the fact that the show went So Meta
their brains exploded just nothing
happened at least Chad's brain should
have exploded that guy can't Incredible
Hulk yeah so how many of them do you
think are aware I think only She-Hulk
knows oh yeah because of the metal Kevin
of it all yeah I definitely like that
Daredevil clearly now in a relationship
is in his Pearl Jam flannel era like
yeah flannel he had some Joy but I don't
think any of them were aware of the
shield experience just like in the comic
like she's got that ability which I I'm
I'm curious if and I don't know if
they'll play with this but I like the
concept of the other guy for Hulk like
Bruce Banner Hulk is the rage monster
what if we're the other guy for her what
if we represent the identity they're in
her other we've been the uh the whole
time
we're not in the comic it's just my
theory because they looked at us it's
fascinating I mean there's this whole uh
Theory right in the Rocky Horror Picture
Show which is the movie that I just
learned this created the concept of
Easter eggs because the cast it had an
Easter egg hunt on the set and they
forgot to pick up all the eggs so
there's like three shots where you can
see a literal Easter egg in the
background also how much of those eggs
yeah
I didn't know this is a moment in my
life right now I've seen that movie 50
times I just learned that but I did my
uh my senior thesis in film school on
the rocky horror pictures
there's this whole theory that like uh
Dr frankenfurter is filming a
documentary and that's why he often
looks directly into the camera and like
says these kind of snarky things right
and so like The Meta nature the fourth
wall breaking of She-Hulk there's a
similar kind of element there of like
she is where she's in a show much like
the Comic version is often aware that
she's in a comic book right
um we're gonna talk more about this like
which characters is there a couple other
characters in this finale that
acknowledged the existence of shows and
their presence of the show we're going
to come back to that what that could
have meant
um but I want to come back to scar yes
so Scar from cigar yeah
um
so also Jen specifically called out or
Kevin called out save it for the movie
yeah do do we think we get uh a planet
Hulk or uh uh some other kind of a whole
centered film soon that features scar
features Jen I I left this finale
feeling confused about Jen's future in
other Marvel properties I feel like a
She-Hulk season 2 makes a lot of sense
but and this is not a criticism more of
a more of my own confusion what is how
does she really fit in to the MCU
outside of a comedic observational comic
you know what I mean like she that's a
redundant phrase but she was really
great at calling out the kind of like
plot redundancies in MCU movies but in
the end the conflict was kind of like
her just her identifying that she had
kind of gotten a bad deal and that had
been treated poorly by the intelligentsy
and by some of the people around her at
work so
does there need to be like a a a a gap
like something to legitimize sounds
weird to say but like if she shows up in
Captain America World War or uh World
Order
is she looking without anything having
happened yeah exactly like is it it's
kind of like the Deadpool thing and like
is Daredevil Born Again gonna have a
She-Hulk presence
in a show that is slightly grounded in
its powered individuals right
traditionally the way that the way I
think they should do Deadpool for
example is I imagine he's gonna know
he's from the fox universe that way he
can swear and they'll mute it in the in
the Marvel Universe and therefore he and
his own movie can be break the fourth
wall I think we'll have an element of
the yellow speech bubble uh in in the
medium of film I think will translate
differently so I think we'll have maybe
voice over break fourth wall I think
they'll do the thing in She-Hulk where
she'll be able to be aware and maybe
have like glance at camera but I think
if they pause the movie A La Cusco and
Emperor's New Groove or something
that'll throw off the Chino so I think
it'll be like in an Avengers film she
might know something and we as an
audience will be like Ah that's cheeky
but I think it'll be delivered deadpan I
think it'll be as as straight man as you
are yeah yeah
so you're saying Daredevil is going to
break the fourth wall I think she
appears in Daredevil but he won't know
what she just like in the beginning when
Hulk goes like like what are you looking
at I think it'll be that kind of vain
exactly it's it's not um uh Zach from
Saved by the Bell yeah timeout timeout
turning and looking none of the other
cast acknowledges for as well this is
some kind of weird thing where like the
other actors or the other characters do
not acknowledge the fourth wall but they
acknowledge her breaking the fourth one
yeah
and that's and that's what I think
Deadpool is going to do as well I think
but the thing about Deadpool is he's
crazy so if Deadpool's talking to
himself the audience and in the world
like in 616 he's gonna be like ah it's
Wade but if She-Hulk does it I think
they can't make that an illusion because
then it's like what's wrong with this
noted lawyer you're right that's wrong
with this lawyer she's very intelligent
what happened to our lawyer yeah that's
why we're the voice you know one thing
in in She-Hulk I would love to see a
deep dive possibly on a YouTube channel
like new rockstars on this uh
technically she only ever like new rock
stars
um yeah they're doing some really great
work out there Derek Ross yeah
um
yeah empty ah but uh right technically
by the time we meet Jennifer in the
beginning of the pilot she has already
because we're going back and forth in
time she's already been turned into
She-Hulk the first time she addresses
she breaks the fourth wall is there
something about becoming a She-Hulk that
like allowed her to break the fourth
wall was law school Jennifer Walters
breaking the fourth wall that's why I
think we're the voice because think
about it she developed it in real time
as she was noticing her powers she
seemed as alarmed by it as us and she
looked at us before she spoke as if
she's being seen by us in the show the
fourth wall was a literal z-axis right
it protruded out it it came out as she
was able to interact with the Disney
plus interaction of the of that the menu
screen I think through the z-axis
looking out at us we're the voice of her
experience so so we're the other guy
that developed in the trauma of the
gamma radiation
uh
love that theory I also wonder speaking
bringing it back because we always ask
depression yeah we are all Jackson
yeah bringing it back to rock your
picture show what if she becomes the no
neck of this of a future Hulk movie
where like you know oh the film opens
with like hey you're back for smart Hulk
action let me tell you the story of my
cousin on sakar Boom cut two whatever
the the plot line of that a bit like
Korg was yeah and uh talking to the kids
in the cave yeah yes yes
um possibilities there but
um just talking about SCAR Where do we
see scar next
oh
killing his brother Mufasa yes the the
sky I'm sorry I should have spelled it
I'm dugging s-k-a-a-r Joe Mufasa I think
Scar from we don't have a lot of Cree
scroll stuff yet we might after the
marbles I think that's where they're
gonna introduce the scree cree scroll
conflict but until then he might take
hopling's spot I think he might end up
marrying or being involved with maybe
Wanda's kid and that performs that that
relationship that's so integral and then
he's a young Avenger like I mean if you
look at the The Avengers in phase four
we've got Thor as a father we've got
Iron Man's kid we've got Ant-Man with
Cassie Lang coming up the Young Avengers
are very uh familial there's nepotism I
didn't even metaphoric Hawkeye with Kate
Bishop right there's a paternal so I
think that he represents the hulks you
know it's all dads with daddy issues
it's all dads with daddy issues so I
think that's where you put them right
like you put him as the hulkling line in
and then you make him a young Avenger
interesting now in the comics scar does
not um he's Perma Hulk right he does not
uh transform back and forth uh he's kind
of a smart Hulk version of his own
character right that's the only form he
ever takes what who's his mom
in some continuities he's got like a
bevy of women that he's just got like a
harem so like who knows okay but isn't
his like in in Hulk form because that's
when he was on sakar was when he was
Perma Hulk so his dick must have been so
big with a regular normal lady I mean
but she's not human she's just a card
she's probably another Gladiator I'm
afraid also also scar is looking he's
got some samoan-esque some Jason Momoa
looking kind of tat kind of stuff going
on so maybe she was a what if it was uh
the grand Masters uh Lady Gaga
yes the the New Zealand actress
the face
throat throw in the chat who you think
uh in in this universe didn't matter
what happened in the comics what what
um Scar's Mama might have been like yeah
who's his mom when we meet her is she
also large and green she's up there in a
Million pieces
uh yeah and and I mean I guess kind of
probably the same answer as as SCAR
Where do we see Bruce painter next
or or Hulk I don't know because what's
what's next secret war secret Invasion
yes series
yeah does he show up does he does he
does he become a kind of wong-esque
figure showing up in other series and
films are we gonna not see him again
until maybe a possible future Hulk movie
is he is he back permanently with his
son or did they come back
first up because this is for the
barbecue right well I honestly like I
don't know like like they were will like
Hulk was willed back by Kevin right
initially and then erased from all of
that and then came back much later
because time works different right so
like who knows how long that was right
and that implies how long Matt and Jenna
been dating
because the levity and Matt obviously
that's a different guy yeah because I
was also like wait she brought him to a
family meeting after a while
that we could have an entirely separate
conversation about how you meant measure
length of a relationship when it is long
distance that's true because it's not
normal time yeah that's true there's a
bit of a dog ears thing there if you
only see each other once every two
months have you really been together for
a year you know what I mean I'm just
throwing that out there I don't think we
see Hulk in secret Invasion I think
that's going to stay with the paranoid
uh you know Cree scroll conflict to come
that's going to lead I think into Miss
Marvel and then I think from there that
leads in armor Wars I think we're
developing into this kind of like
paranoid distrust of government dodc
Young Avengers I think that's one story
could we see I mean could we maybe
justify an appearance a number worse
it's there's gonna be some sciency stuff
going on there is some Sciences you know
Bruce is still maybe maybe the premium
and a genius in the MCU we don't know
he's got some competition if scar is
kind of permanently in a smart Hulk mode
and he's got you know presumably a
knowledge of alien technology and his
father's DNA and aptitude of earth-bound
Technology perhaps he could be helping
in the armor Wars perhaps he could be a
young scientist again there will be lots
of content on the new Rockstar Channel
about Scar and his appearance ages okay
so we're presuming he was not conceived
and born during this trip to sicar but
maybe on the previous trip to sakar Thor
Ragnarok uh covered that still only
makes him what
eight years old how yeah not that I
don't know in the Canon of MCU when did
Ultron end
Age of Ultron was 2013. yeah so if Hulk
flew to sicar then right in his ships
night one just got done hey before he
got Gladiator I mean well also we don't
know what the gestational period on
Sakara is like they could have babies
and a half there you go yeah and and you
come out like a baby giraffe you're
ready to stand
and warriors I still don't get how
giraffes do that man I'll never
understand
yeah ran out
like like a Mario character
a voice by Chris Pratt it's me Mario
uh oh okay she hooked season two yeah
yeah do we get it phase five
I hope so there's some blank spots in
the in that release calendar could be
filled in by something like a Moon
Knight season two a She-Hulk season two
I I would love a She-Hulk season two
that had a
explored the duality of Jennifer she
humped the attorney and She-Hulk the
hero with one trial not a like case of
the week I would like one long trial
over like eight or nine episodes and
then and then obviously a b storyline of
fighting you know bad people or whatever
I think there's a really a strong place
for in the MCU where there is now
established government and and oversight
right we're gonna have that in Iron Wars
I mean armor Wars and secret Invasion I
think there's a place for her to kind of
explain like hey this is what's going on
with uh kamala's law with all these
things I think there's a purpose for the
show and I also think it does allow a
certain kind of levity and and World
expansion like what if expands
opportunity I think She-Hulk expands
um uh B plots like you can do a lot
after a shield show with the with the
fourth wall break speaking of which what
if is a great opportunity to have Scar
and Hulk right to explore some more yeah
with some other like what if I mean
literal what if what if all kind of kid
right yeah yeah but or I mean obviously
those are kind of side you know surprise
or interdimensional tangents but maybe
we could have like what if scar was
hulkling or something I also thinks I
think scar might become the Raging Hulk
that people want yeah I don't think
Bruce Banner necessary yeah I thought
maybe he'd go to World War Hulk he'd
lose his wife and child that would turn
him into a rage monster then The
Illuminati's like Holt don't come back
Hulk comes back wreaks Havoc that's kind
of how it happens in the comics I think
since he came back intelligent wearing a
polo maybe his son is going to be the
Raging Hulk monster that everyone wants
to be like the Hulk because Scar's not
that he's smart but he's not smart like
so I think maybe he he's kind of our our
stand-in for like 70 days no I 100 agree
because like you know this guy's just a
kid and life is a nightmare yeah no I
100 agree with that I think he's going
to be an angsty teen because like we
already saw like angsty Groot you know
like teens are mad teens are capable of
taking over the world he's coming from
this maybe from the Gladiator pits of
sakar right yeah rough and tough
atmosphere
tatted uh he came out the womb tatted
also if you think the new rock stars
won't have a Hulk [ __ ] confirmed
thumbnail in the next week yeah they we
will we'll have a thumbnail to go with
it and boy oh boy are you going to want
to see that we will find the absolute
worst CGI Hulk phase too yeah
well
sorry did you go tears one more time
perfect flip it perfect clip it done yes
what were you saying oh yeah I I want to
know how Hulk found out he had a son
like did he just get like a text message
when he like got back to Earth and it
was like bro WYD question yeah yeah
WYD kid is that obviously the ship
delivering the message in the beginning
could have been paternity related or it
could have been a trojan horse to lure
him back to
Cigars
Cigars is uh
gangsters all right huh come here I want
to take out Jimmy thumbnails it's also
to be fair to our uh thumbnails on the
channel we don't know that Hulk [ __ ]
because a big plot line in this movie
Stolen blood somehow they just you know
they made it in a lab with a pen and a
pad
box of scraps
um uh I hope we get a lot more of scar
in the near future because yeah as koi
was mentioning there's a lot of fun
potential there and just like Hulk has
been the last kind of 10 years of Marvel
films he's often best in buddy and pair
up yeah kind of Rose either in with Jen
him with Thor him with even Iron Man
those scenes are so great and all those
Avengers movies
put a scar on all of our hearts he's got
LeBron James hairline just slowly
shifting all over his head like a jigsaw
puzzle all right who knows
um real quick a couple other characters
from this series where do we think we'll
see them next Abomination I mean I know
you have a theory parody porn get out of
here definitely you have a legitimate
are you serious
sorry guys no more jokes don't
understand is so weird for me it's
already been really weird I don't know
what to do I'm sorry Whitney I got a
mandate from uh from the bosses above
that comedy was out and it was time for
me to take this job a little more
seriously I don't like it make it stop
check out my secret blog
okay it's called Tommy's tunnels that's
where we go deep in all the Marvel news
all the secrets and ooze that they're
not going to show you on this show okay
go to my website at
www.canadian
government.legalcannabis.edu okay anyway
abomination
is gonna be I think the reason he was
given that harsh sentence of 10 more
years back in back in that you know
Plexiglas prison that he goes to is
because it's obviously a bargaining chip
to get him to join the Thunderbolts and
they're gonna hide him at commentage so
that people can't be like what are you
just letting this guy Run free it's like
no Wong is working with Val and whoever
else in the Thunderbolts right now to
keep uh Abomination and Emil Blonsky uh
part of the tip and I think botsky will
gladly do it I don't think I think he is
somewhat reformed I I I love this idea
because it is tenure seems ridiculous he
didn't break any the only law he broke
was converting back to imagination he
didn't harm anybody there was no
assaults or anything like that
um he was conducting like a weird
seminar though which is kind of hey if
if that's legal we got to prosecute a
lot of weird I'll tell you what time
Tony what's the Tony Robbins he's gonna
get the electric chair but the in-cell
Seminars the other thing I love about
the theory which it's so specific but
also that graphic that we saw from
with Elena with Red Guardian with
everybody you could just see over the
top of that a big hulking you need a big
I think there's maybe more than one too
I think we might get I think we might
get some a couple Big Bad Boys uh or
girls or Big Bad Girls you know
they're gonna do a bait and switch with
Thunderbolts like in the comics the
Thunderbolts are villains that are
pretending to be heroes that know
they're bad guys that are that are
tricking the audience I think the
Thunderbolts movie might trick Us in
that they've got a bunch of villains
that are reformed they've all been in
therapy look at that lineup those are
all like they've gotten better what if
they're doing things that they think are
good but we find that are evil what if
they're working for a government or
something that's sending them on
missions and it's like you know the
classic Bond thing like you killed
someone for the you know MI6 but they
were actually a good guy what if the
Thunderbolts are heroes actually in
their own mind and then they find out
they've done wrong things yes that would
work for Abomination like he's like I'm
just trying to get you know on the right
side of things yeah so it might be like
that is like where he claimed to be
originally like he you know like when he
was explained to Jen he was like I
didn't know what I was doing I just got
the serum I wanted to save the world
yeah zero so it would just be like that
just another mission all of them right
and I can see that for uh because when
they said when they said Bucky I was
like wait a second because Bucky is a
good guy but he's got trauma in his past
so I can see Bucky being someone that's
like leading this team that finds that
the orders they're on or not right right
well those yeah I mean that was kind of
like uh everybody in the gun Suicide
Squad right Cena was secretly doing was
like just trying to burn down those
files and everybody else thought they
were just trying to take out the thinker
or whatever or not the Thinker yeah yeah
yeah anyway
but the thinker was the PS Pete uh you
know Doctor Who Pete Capaldi Peter
Capaldi cousins with Louis Capaldi the
Scottish singer a little fun fact for
you guys and that's the type of clean
fun facts you're gonna get from me now
that the jokes are dead all right uh
Daredevil will next see and Daredevil
and Echo right oh yeah yeah because uh
um timeline wise we will get Echo before
we get uh Daredevil born again so I like
that
um Wong I mean everything right he will
be in every uh Marvel property that we
see for the next 20 years yeah I think I
think long is contractually obviously
Benedict Wong is forced show up he sits
in one of those prison cells the
Abomination is in with his DJ booth that
he likes to play practice I think he
just lives at Pinewood Studios in
Atlanta and uh if if you just go to
craft service and if we need somebody
for this scene Benedict come on over
here all right uh now what about now
this is going to lead us into an almost
entirely other conversation Kevin do we
ever see Kevin again we need to talk
about Kevin we need to talk about Kevin
get Tilda in here let's talk about Kevin
uh what do you think is that is that a
one-off just for that scene for kind of
the gag joke of that scene I thought
that it was just like really lazy and
Kevin feige did not show up himself I'm
like you are a lazy we developed that
robot
I gave it a hat they gave it the
acronyms genius I'm not gonna lie you
guys I did not like Kevin no I'm not a
Kevin I love Kevin I did not like Kevin
because you expected foggy then the bait
and switch was no I didn't expect feige
because okay because I watch all shows
with subtitles me too me too they did
they gave it away
hey Disney plus that is an excellent
point Whitney just made I was also
spoiled because I was watching with
subtitles you spoiled the reveal Disney
plus hey Disney plus you fumbled the
bags also I was watching Bambi the other
night and there was a subtitle that said
gunshots before Bambi's mom got shot so
guess what I started crying before I
even saw it with my own two eyes I
started crying from Reading that's the
last time Tommy Tommy's getting spoiled
for a 65 year old animated films over
here next thing you're gonna tell me
Snow White has to be kissed Back to Life
by a man no thank you 2022 six and
subtitles are Bruce Willis dead yeah
yeah I already uh I feel like that's a
detail that never would have been missed
if real Kevin were involved that's right
you know what I mean fight is that level
of detail that's what I'm saying he's
out there typing the subtitles himself
he's like no no no just gonna type Kevin
I will say this I think I am closer to
uh on Whitney's side of the street on
this issue than I am on koi I don't want
to ruffle any feathers here I will just
say this if we get more of Kevin K
period Eve period v period i period end
period I hope it's very sparing
I think I don't want to be like the new
porg or the new BB I think it's a great
joke one time maybe twice what I can't
see anything other than diminishing
returns that there is a like you know
robot AI unless all of our favorite
movies unless they do a Wizard of Oz
where at some point pay no attention
operating Kevin it's like promoter I'd
be okay with that that's the scenario
that in which I like I just want to see
Kevin feige with a Kevin hat now I want
to see the cake in the eye and on the
Hat hit us at the next thing they pull
it back and it's Jeff Johns and he's
like see I wasn't messing up all the DC
movies I was making your favorite MCU
movies
uh I love that
um Christian unpronounceable already
Super Chat Kevin is the one above all
obviously there's a comic book
precedence for this right like there's
always an extra layer above uh the gods
we know in the MCU and the final layer
is the guy who's drawing the comic book
right
um there's kind of that here though I
I wonder there is a way maybe you could
tie this back in and not have it Be So
Meta and so forth while breaking I think
of the boys on Amazon where we're in a
world with actual superheroes where they
make the movies
so it's like She-Hulk exists while a
She-Hulk show is also being filmed
starring She-Hulk maybe that's almost a
way they could make it make sense to
bring back a character like Kevin and
something else where he's the network
head of Disney plus which exists in a
world in which Captain America and Hulk
and people are real Jen Walter's cousin
and her are getting a car accident she's
in trauma and has a mental break during
the car accident she's a big movie fan
she sees all this happen in Real Time
season two is all a dream they made the
joke it was all my dreams yes
oh no yes real quick I don't want to
send this down a wormhole here yeah how
does how does Jennifer know about X-Men
she's God she's Christ she's Christ Our
Lord this is the danger of like breaking
the fourth wall so hard this is a danger
I sound like I'm working for a uh far
more toxicity
she was a female no no but I think
fourth wall breaking in general when
it's like Daredevil or Deadpool and he's
just such a lunatic and like you don't
take anything he says seriously it
doesn't matter when it's Jennifer
Walters who like you said is an attorney
is this really smart articulate
character and it's like wait I think she
has omniscient thought you just meant to
say Deadpool I think you said darede I
did mean to say Deadpool uh Deadpool
Wade Wilson is crazy yes thank you uh to
be very clear uh Jennifer well I think
it's you can't tell the line between
taking that character and what they do
can you take any of it seriously it's a
show called She-Hulk we're crying out
loud but you know what I mean like are
we supposed to get invested in what Jen
Walters Jennifer Walters and She-Hulk
does if they have god-like knowledge of
everything going on in all universes in
the world well I think that's why you
need to keep her as the only one that's
aware of the fourth wall like we were
saying other people being confused by it
whereas Deadpool can like rant in a
corner by himself I think that there
needs to be like she only does that
around people she trust or that only
happens in certain times because she
didn't come back to that barbecue
talking about any of that she didn't
reference any of it again she didn't
come back to the fight she just walked
up to Todd Phelps and was was
acknowledging like what he'd done but
she didn't mention it so I I think as
long as you keep that for her it can't
work but it is a very fine line and I
love uh I think it was voss's theory of
Kang inventing Kevin so we're gonna talk
about that and actually uh everybody has
a video about this coming out of the
channel in the next couple days keep an
eye out for that but yeah does the he
who remains because that would make
sense if you've got an overarching
timeline structure maybe this entire
show was in a variant timeline maybe
this Bruce Banner is not our Bruce
Banner maybe all these experiences
that's why Daredevil suits yellow maybe
all of these things are a variant
Universe the one above all is
supervising this universe with the Kevin
that Kevin keeps track of all these
things
all of it up here
I just realized something uh on boob
rockstars Whitney's name is uh Brittany
Wham slammingham
Tommy's been green pilled
quick real quick we have a lot more
stuff we want to talk about we want to
come back to Daredevil we want to come
back to the that weird stuff that uh you
uh Emil blonski and Wong were saying to
each other but real quick we want to
shout out some of the folks that help us
bring this show to you uh and we
appreciate all of our sponsors we
appreciate your support of our sponsors
when you click on the link that's in
this uh that's in the video description
when you use a promo code or something
like that you are uh both hopefully
getting yourself a great deal on
something but also supporting us and
when you personally venmo me it means so
much yeah it means so much personally
venmo us uh cash app Tommy at Z huddle
uh okay
um magic uh we want to shout out magical
Gathering Arena
um if you if you're like me and you used
to play Magic the Gathering a bunch okay
there were many a middle school
um cafeteria they got some Mana tapped
on it okay and that's not a dirty
reference yeah that's honest but um I've
really enjoyed coming back to the game
through Magic the Gathering Arena which
is this really cool mobile app made by
our friends at Magic the Gathering
they're celebrating their 30th
Anniversary since the the original game
was created and in 30 years 30 years it
was like 15 at the most God time flies
for 15 of those years I did I got bit by
a snake
slept for 15 years Rick van stinkle over
here okay
um uh okay we've gotten we've lost the
thread ah but go out uh you can click
the link in in this video's description
uh there are two links one will help you
download the game for free and it's a
lot of fun like it's uh the uh play
mechanisms in the game are really
intuitive easy to learn you can collect
all the cards play uh there's a great
tutorial as you first download it also
there's a link in this video's
description to their YouTube channel
which they just launched which has a lot
of kind of support content tutorials
things like that support uh the break
room and get yourself a really fun game
I've been playing this at home
um sitting on the couch in between shows
and things like that Tommy Tommy's
laughing sitting on the couch the couch
no I'm laughing at a comment oh okay how
dare you no I don't know look at Zach he
doesn't sit much he's not sedentary
that's right uh but uh uh go go get
yourself Magic the Gathering Arena uh
just click the link in the description
below download the game for free and
begin assembling Your Dragon deck today
hell yeah my couch has a Tommy shaped
hole in it so it feels like I'm being
hugged by myself spoon from behind by me
what a dream that's pretty great uh real
quick some other
um lingering questions uh yeah does Jen
still mean well does Jen does Jennifer
still work at GLK and H I feel like we
it's implied she got a job back when she
walked in in her power suit from Luke
Jacobson right I agree I I can't imagine
she wouldn't they would be fools if she
was cleared of all charges I think she'd
have a wrongful termination
do you think her employment is purely
contingent on her being a She-Hulk yes
yes because as soon as she has the
inhibitor no longer and it's like no
more yeah it's like when like I mean no
offense to child children of TV stars
but when like they're casting projects
and roles that are not super demanding
of their acting abilities you're like
right this doesn't make sense for this
person because they're selling movie
tickets or they or people are tuning in
to see like hey can the son of this guy
actually act not calling out anyone
specifically this is a direct assault on
Wyatt Russell Scott Eastwood
Patrick Schwarzenegger oh no I'm talking
about Arnold's other kid on Dancing With
the Stars by the way you could have a
kid with a maid do it guys I gotta say
2023 sleep with the staff okay all right
that's not an official endorsement of
new records it is it is it's for me
that's an interesting thing I say is
canon in the ncu the nru that sounds
like the policies over at Boombox Stars
I don't know um with sloppy backboard
whoa
uh CEOs Lobby record
I got hey that's where hogs kids are
born on Chicago
black stars
um I do like part of Jen's interaction
with Kevin and we're going to come back
to this in our mandatory fund segment
later but uh they're kind of
acknowledging right some of the tropes
of Marvel and superhero films and I I
love this moment when she says that
Marvel has been historically light when
it comes to sex yeah and the MCU that's
true what do you think this has
definitely been the horniest Marvel
property yeah
um I'm of two thoughts of it okay I I
think on one hand
it's okay I think for She-Hulk and
Deadpool and titles like that to include
sex and you know I mean it's healthy to
you know acknowledge that adults have
sex with each other I think for like an
Avengers team-up movie you're venturing
into a territory of there's a lot of
eight and nine year olds that don't
necessarily need like it could be
implies and they face it yeah I mean I
don't mean to sound like you know
approved like like you know the American
Value Center like being like anything
that's not just people eating plain
toast offends me I just think that
there's a pretty distinct age from when
you can pretty much imply sex without an
eight nine a ten year old having any
idea what's happening and then there's
you know two naked legs pressing up
against two other naked legs I think it
just depends on the title I have no
problem with it in cheah I certainly
have no problem with it in Deadpool it
doesn't matter what I think but I think
Tommy wants Captain America to stay a
virgin I want Captain America I want
Captain America spread so wide open that
it looks like we're staring into the
Grand Canyon Captain America to show
hole for you that's right damn that's
America's [ __ ]
that's America's hole I think it's like
any like any other comic property right
like different comic show refer to an
audiences so I agree I definitely think
that like I don't think the stuff in
eternals was gratuitous like that an
eight-year-old would be like what are
those shoulders doing right that was
like very appropriate yeah smothering
her also like 2008 was 14 years ago so a
lot of the audience has aged 14 years so
we do need more R-rated things and I
also think that there's and this is a
bigger conversation but it is kind of
backwards that in this country like
violence and blood is more accepting
than sex yeah so if if a company as big
as Marvel wants to at least chip away at
the expectations of we can main murder
cause harm we can turn people to dust
but we can't show people loving each
other that's an issue so I'd rather a
giant company like the mouse actually
take that head on because if no one else
can do it to as big of an impact so
people [ __ ] they should let me throw it
out what will be besides maybe a
She-Hulk season two what will be the
next horniest MCU press
oh you know you guys say that but I
think secret Invasion Coleman's gonna
get [ __ ]
no stranger to the sex scene herself the
Khaleesi Samuel L Jackson you think he's
not getting ass by the way Capital One
commercials Samuel Jackson should be
playing Nick Fury and they should be
Canon Jennifer Garner should be playing
Electro they should be Canon that's true
Alec Baldwin should be playing himself
and it should not be anywhere near a
loaded weapon on those okay okay oh
sorry so sorry everyone but well and we
haven't had uh ratings announced yet for
the upcoming Disney plus series we don't
know which ones could be tvma things
like She-Hulk wanted Disney put a tvma
on their channel on their thing I know
they do in other countries but they put
that all on Hulu right well the the uh
Netflix series that are now on Disney
plus are edited um is that right am I
correct did they edit did they edit
Daredevil before they put it on is it
just as Graphics I think you just click
through to like the adult version I
think it's the same because there's that
like age verification
what if Loki a series were not expecting
it is super sexy horny romantic whatever
what if we get something in Echo or iron
Wars or every time he was joking but
secret Invasion right if that's a great
spy story right often spy stories are
interwoven with seduction honey pots you
know uh intimacy all right honey pot now
you're bringing me back to college Old
Tommy honey pops over here oh it's also
like you need that show is an Espionage
Thriller that's not made for kids little
kids and I think that's important to
have that designation well it's kind of
it's like it's like Android not to go
back to Android which you should all be
watching uh that show is clearly not
like the show you introduce your
six-year-old kid to Star Wars in right
I've been falling in love with right
you're like this is Gonna Make You Love
8 000 supplementary Star Wars stories
it's like no and or is for us Road dirty
dogs and sitting in putting up with
putting up with Cantina songs and weird
hologram dances and CG jar jars serves
our nickel yeah
and it all led up to to Diego Luna
saying [ __ ] on a Star Wars show and it
was worth it baby and it's been worth it
to Disney property like prey is not for
children and it's owned by Hellraiser is
a Disney property now for crying out
loud in on Hulu today Sebastian Stan uh
weird Cannibal movie fresh is
technically a Disney owned uh thing deep
throat is it that is false Debbie Does
Dallas no he's part of the NFL not the
NFL is on ABC no in ESPN we can get
there guys Pirates no spaghetti's
Revenge the most expensive adult film
ever made
um okay real quick we want to shout out
a couple other folks that help us bring
this show to you aspiration uh you've
heard us talking about them all week
thank you to aspiration making small
decisions every day to help the planet
can have a big impact over time if you
keep your money in a lot of these
standard bank accounts they're lending
it out to fund oil and coal and all
kinds of stuff that's not good for the
planet switch to the planet side and get
yourself aspiration they're a fossil for
this is okay this is a bit of a tongue
twister fossil fuel free fossil fuel
freezer free faster fossil fuel free
um all my fossil fuel free freaks out in
the chat
and they let uh they they plant a tree
every time you swipe your debit card
which is wow that what a nice thought
that is as you're getting your kombucha
if you use the chip
that's a great question they burn a tree
I think no I think it's a swipe it's a
chip it's a chop them down and then they
piss on it aspiration would never burn a
tree
um but uh they've already planted over
100 million trees that's a lot of trees
it's like I can't even count on that
many trees in one hand
this is a great idea offset capitalism
by doing some good for the world plant
trees and the nice thing about
aspiration it's not just a do-good or
thing it's also a good bank right no
credit check no overdraft fees
um they're doing a lot of good stuff so
make your dollars make a difference open
an aspiration account at aspiration.com
breakroom debit that's the important
part the links in this in the
description of this video uh move your
money out of fossil fuels help save the
planet with your aspiration debit card
open your account at aspiration.com
break room debit today
aspiration.com break room debit terms
and conditions apply and then hey Zach
yes sir let me handle this oh okay It
Ain't Easy Being Cheesy but it's Easy
Being Green baby we want to thank our
sponsors at Athletics yes we are huge
fans of ag1 which makes it so easy to
get all my daily nutrition in one easy
and tasty drink believe it or not your
boy who is a total train wreck of a
human drinks ag-1 every day and that's
what's keeping this all together it's
the glue all right every scoop of ag-1
has 75 high quality vitamins minerals
Whole Food Source superfoods probiotics
and adaptogens baby special blend of
ingredients supports a lot of Health
stuff including better sleep quality
mental Clarity and alertness reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
alert me with convenient daily nutrition
it's just alertness it's just one scoop
and a cup of water every day that's it
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase with your second purchase just
ag1 hun and that's well worth it all you
have to do is visit athleticgreens.com
break room again that is
athleticgreens.com slash break room to
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional uh
Insurance thank you to athletic greens
for sponsoring the show we want to shout
out some of the super chats and some of
the things uh you folks have been
noticing or pointing out
um GSU Eagle asking
looking back on the first episode of the
series what was Titania doing busting
into that courtroom
Jessica Clemens is I think
the only person
ringing this Bell loudly enough that the
story that they gave us was that she had
low blood sugar and was in traffic court
and she thought I think Jessica you call
in if I'm misquoting you Jessica's
theory is that she was actually paid by
the law firm to kind of cause the
mistrial I think that makes perfect
sense I think Titania is a modern day
influencer for hire and that means they
I mean if you know influencers now and I
do oh I do they will do anything for
money people send me hats and I make 20
minute videos for them I don't care
we're chills we're Shields we put your
chest I mean your hair in his chest
that's right
120 Super Chat I'm shoving hot chemical
peppers down my throat to no I mean I'm
still not walking right from that okay
my doctor took a look at my chest we did
a full X-ray and my doctor said
my doctor is Wired Magazine I just write
into the letters to the editor for
medical advice I I like that because
like if there were a grand conspiracy
you would think that would be revealed
by the end of the series right maybe it
was I was like you were kind of joking
in the office but I think it might be
true she just loves busting through
walls yeah she's like the Kool-Aid yeah
she's just the Kool-Aid she's the
Kool-Aid that one power she's like what
else am I going to do I that was one
character that I know you couldn't
really justify spending much more time
on her I'd love that character uh
Jamila Jamil played her I love the the
Brandon and I were talking the voice is
so good that I thought she might have
been the funniest part of the show like
her reactions to stuff I I need more if
they make a season two I think she's got
to be a friend of me of She-Hulk right
yeah she's in the comics a lot of the
time totally works great I'm all for it
Carlos V asking is She-Hulk a Nexus
being or could she even be at the same
level as The Watcher well we I mean the
n in Kevin is Nexus right yeah which
kind of I think justifies if you want to
be like oh this they just kind of took
the piss out of all the MCU and said
it's a writer's room and a robot if
Kevin the robot is somehow you know I
threw Eric's video about King is
probably going into this some sort of
Nexus Machinery or has Nexus AI that
would maybe explain how they're able to
manipulate the events of the MCU a
little more I don't know if She-Hulk is
although breaking the fourth wall and
knowing all of the things about X-Men
and stuff does kind of imply she at
least has Nexus dare I say sensitivities
I would say Texas implies like it's
above and overarching everything right
like a Nexus point in Marvel like that
that's a key so I feel like the the
robot is but I would say she just has
access to it I don't think she is
um yeah I I like those ideas uh shout
out to the other folks in the uh Super
Chat you Capri to hear for the cookies
you could read that a good point time
works differently in sakar uh Age of
Ultron was 2015.
um I think in in Marvel Canon not the
film release but like that that's the
year in which
um in the 6166 OR with the 166 I always
get to screwed up
um so interesting
the Marvels
that's what world by night is
um uh here for the cookie stand uh re
Matt at the barbecue uh it's the finale
Jen wanted oh yeah he was there for the
same reason he literally dropped out of
the sky at blonsky's compound yeah it is
interesting and if you think of like her
influencing the writing of her own show
yeah wouldn't she write that like it's
both like she gets everybody that she
loves back for the finale she gets her
man all the cousins back with twists
like that that's a good interesting
theory that is her version of the the
ending yeah
and does who Among Us doesn't except for
Dwayne The Rock Johnson
the best Comic-Con of his life it's so
much fun
time for mandatory low-key
thanks thanks everyone for joining
mandatory fund where I advise three
people to uh participate in a segment
with me uh today
Uh something's not right yeah so it is
what's wrong there's so much lower
energy than normal
yeah I gotta go oh right here okay well
I hope you feel better when you're yeah
I'm back I'm so sorry guys um uh
hopefully someone else can host that uh
yeah let me just uh call out uh mj2997
in the chat so he's super jazzed for
season two uh he wants more Miss Lonnie
agreed she's excellent and also I was
pointing out we didn't get she's one of
the most talented dramatic actresses
obviously anybody that watch any Orphan
Black knows like how incredibly talented
she is and like this show is a great way
for her to stretch
um a lot of her comedic chops didn't
have as many dramatic moments I would
love to see maybe a season two give her
more oh my God wow it is I T Jason
bourse told
okay
the Syracuse psychopath
the Motor City Mad man it's not for
mandatory fun the segment's so spooky we
keep our graphic too
oh the segment's so frightening we hit
the graphic like lightning here we go oh
wow yes the segment's so enthralling we
keep the graphic rolling here we go and
now mandatory fun is when I invite my
three dearest friends in the whole wide
world to sit with me for a little fun
they can't get out of
now
today we are going to speak directly to
K period e period v period i period n
period Kevin himself and give our Marvel
gripes in a segment we call dear Kevin
who would like to go first I'll go first
okay just real quick so as if there was
a Kevin running the break room or
something like that that we are much
like Jen was complaining about the
ending of her show we were going to be
complaining about yes okay is it about
our world or or the 616 world yeah it's
about the MCU 616 yes I realize I'm
busting busting out this mask it was
made for a child Jason okay the my face
grew the mask didn't I was born this way
I'm wearing a Jason mask so you better
talk fast I got the mask on Jason I Was
Born This Way don't be a drag just kill
a queen don't be a drag just kill a
queen okay all right implying I murdered
the queen now
Kevin oh Kevin let me tell you something
that I haven't seen nearly nearly nearly
enough about
what's going on with the ten rings Kevin
ah you set us up with a movie you set us
up with a possible new leader of the ten
Rings you give a Shang Chi Great
Character you give us all that fun you
bring back Trevor Slattery what's going
on Kevin when is the release date coming
release the date show the movie give us
a teaser at least bring simulu back into
Cameo and something secret Invasion C
moves give me something let me see him
Proof of Life on simu show me yeah yeah
come on the show come on come on the
break room you guys okay that's great
somebody else have another dear Kevin
gripe
I've I've got one maybe as as you think
um
uh this is uh I don't know this is super
specific but we've gotten every time a
Marvel film comes out about a month
after it's theatrical release or maybe
around the time of its home video
release or whatever we get all these
deleted scenes sometimes the CGI is not
done or it's like if it's a taika
watichi film it's like a thousand
alternate comedic takes or whatever
right I want some six hour versions of
these Marvel films to start getting
released make a party of it really
re-release it into the theaters is like
a midnight movie thing what if it's like
um they did the the whole second movie
off of Anchorman right yeah
they could put out a second movie I bet
there's enough of Thor 11 Thunder yeah
for you to at least give us like a 45
minute special it's just weird Russell
Crowe scenes
maybe get drunk with friends uh and
watch that like Marvel start putting
this stuff out take my money Kevin Kevin
come on Kevin
anyone else all right Kevin I feel like
we've experienced lots and lots of
disparate uh uh afterlife uh overtones
and I am wondering with the field of
reads as well as the thing on the other
side of the veil in Miss Marvel as well
as the gods and Thor will we find out a
cohesive unit is there going to be a
conversation perhaps with Kang maybe
it's coming maybe there's something to
make it maybe the beyonder he sees all
maybe those are other Realms but I would
prefer to know if they are other Realms
what that view is within the MCU I'd
love a little cohesion
nice that's a good one find a way to
bring those together show me that
they're all like uh different lands on
the Disneyland Park you know I have tree
of life right
the with Skarsgard there showing all the
different Realms I'd love to find out
that maybe like we are one we're the the
tree and then when you die depending on
your beliefs you go out to the different
branches so I've always seen it
at the different realities of your
existence and your belief system is the
the bases where you land because our
Consciousness basically just ceases to
be in this realm so maybe your
Consciousness based on your choices
lands at one of these other you go to
Jewish Heaven yeah
superhero and you just ended up going to
like a really basic head just bored just
like aerobics
is going to Catholic heaven and it's
like buddy are you sure
like yeah they're not yeah I think
Heaven is probably for our reality like
it it's like it's a car right there's a
sense of time so maybe it's just like
when our brain shorts out as we die it
extends time so our belief system is
whatever we think it's going to be until
we're just carbon so maybe in the MCU
it's however you think it's going to end
spread throughout time and that's your
last Bastion of thought well for me
Heaven's always going to be a bowl of
lukewarm popcorn repeats of One Tree
Hill and my mother's severed head right
by myself oh my God that's Jason's stuff
style everyone team Jason Beck fees or
what what's what was your name t Jason
Beck Voorhees okay great but I've got a
secret for you oh I'm not t Jason at all
it's me guys
Happy Halloween that's our show
oh no are you okay Tommy's broken Tommy
bro
uh oh uh uh my cat is cuter than yours
in the Super Chat talk about Tiamat
Kevin yes somebody must address the
giant yeah yeah I was gonna say that for
mine which is what is going on with
Tiamat there has to be okay so like I'm
imagining right that they have like you
know like you know like the Furbo dog
camera that you can leave behind when
you go and you can check on your pet
they definitely have one of those for
TMA and I bet that there's just like a
constant live stream where you can watch
it in the MCU but I need we need that
what are people doing are they not
freaking out have they turned it into a
tourist destination yet how much does it
cost to get to the top see if you could
do like a little ski lift ride
also the migratory bird population is
definitely embracing Tiamat yeah can you
imagine the uh volume of guano and yeah
[Music]
who wants them they say they give you
Powers 25 of pebble there's a guy doing
that I bet is this guy live on a cigar
this guy lives in New Jersey oh okay and
with that where you can finally check
your final breaker and box of uh New
Jersey has been insulted that's the show
can end uh thank you all so much we'll
keep there's a lot to talk about shields
we'll probably still be talking about it
more still have some home tomorrow thank
you what a great finally absolutely yes
finally for the finale thank you uh
superhero world uh TD Jones banana
everybody that was in the Super chat
today we appreciate you Christian
unpronounceable coming through with some
uh more Canadian doubloons in the chat
yeah
um tune in tomorrow fun Friday episode
uh I think we'll uh finale talk about
Andor on it we will yes apologize yeah
um finale we'll get to it yeah for real
I wasn't on the show yesterday
I mean we we had been speculating on who
was going to die everybody but mine
could we I know everybody died except
for the one guy that taught me I am
doing so bad at the game that I have
rigged to have total control of all
right yeah thank you all so much thank
you nikoi and Whitney
joining us uh it's always a pleasure to
have you both here uh I'd love to have
you back sometime soon thank you all if
you haven't already and you've made it
this far into this video hit like And
subscribe on this video hit like
whatever you do it every little thumbs
up you've shown in for liking thank you
thank you go back to drinking on Fridays
Lillian we can't I have a monitor on my
ankle yeah it goes off I guess Tommy has
like the Hulk inhibitor now that's true
for 10 years you know what
I'll sneak some boosters oh my God you
think those four mugs are empty tune in
to find out folks bye laters